this morning we're going to hear from a
woman who's making shocking allegations
against gallane maxwell in her new book
silence no more surviving my journey to
hell and back sarah ransom says she was
recruited into jeffrey epstein's alleged
sex trafficking ring back in 2006.
maxwell as you know is currently on
trial she's charged with recruiting and
grooming underage girls for jeffrey
epstein now she denies all the charges
and ransom's claims are not part of this
case against her
ransom who is now 37 years old was in
court for the first day of the trial
last week she settled a civil lawsuit
with maxwell back in 2018. we'll hear
directly from her in just a moment but
first here's a look at some of her story
and those very disturbing allegations
against gallane maxwell and jeffrey
epstein
what does today mean for you all sarah
ransom says she was recruited into
jeffrey epstein's world when she was 22.
in her book ransom says she was
approached at a new york city nightclub
by a girl about her age who offered to
introduce her to jeffrey epstein saying
he helps a lot of young girls achieve
their dreams
days later ransom went to epstein's
private island in the caribbean with
other young girls
including her recruiter and gelane
maxwell the abuse she says started on
that island where epstein raped her i'm
here representing civil society it was
maxwell she says who often called her to
epstein's room she writes while jeffrey
was reeling in children by the dozens
galen was shoring up his social
credibility epstein she says promised to
help her get into a prestigious fashion
school with a caveat she had to lose 30
pounds off of her 5 foot 9 frame
she writes you'll need to get down to
114 pounds
instructions she says came from galaine
maxwell like many of maxwell and
epstein's accusers ransom's trouble
started long before she met the pair in
2006. i had no idea the
lions
then that i was actually getting into
ransom was born and raised in south
africa by a single mother she was raped
for the first time at the age of 11 she
says by her mother's boyfriend years
before she met epstein and maxwell
ransom says she turned to sex work to
stave off homelessness
when she escaped epstein in 2007 she
turned to sex work again something she
deeply regrets and writes in her book
i've made regretful choices in the name
of survival and acted at times in
breathless desperation
i am not perfect and that is the point
now we spoke to sarah ransom ahead of
the release of her book she told us why
she was afraid to speak out for so long
sarah thank you so much for coming thank
you for having me here i know i i can't
imagine how you're feeling we've just
looked at um a piece about your life as
we sit here today helen maxwell's trial
is underway
the gulen that you write about in your
book and the gulen that the
defense has laid out on the very first
day
we're being told that she's being used
as a scapegoat
that
she was not involved in any of the sex
trafficking
what do you think when you hear that it
makes me sick
i remember very distinctly
before
i'd been on jeffrey epstein's island
for a few days with some other survivors
who had been raped
as well as i had been raped
and
just before gilean arrived
jeffrey
very very clearly
said to me you answer to gilean
you do exactly what she says
and you don't cross her
bearing in mind from the first time i'd
been on the island
jeffrey said to me
i will kill you
i will kill your parents
if you ever run
if you ever tell anybody or if you ever
go to the authorities
uh so you ever tell anybody what if
about the reps and about what he was
doing to me
so
i was already frightened i was terrified
for my life so when jeffrey said to me
you do not cross her
i knew
you do not cross it i have so many
examples of how elaine
not only tortured me and abused me
but other survivors
when guilin had been on the island i'd
been on the island for for a few days
um
jeffrey had like this outside patio with
with seating
and
she looked at me and she walked over to
me
and she said jeffrey wants you
and
i i completely froze
and she grabbed my arm and marched me
into jeffrey's room where i was then
wrecked
so when she says that she had nothing to
do and she had no idea
she was a facilitator
she was
jeffrey's right hand woman she
orchestrated everything the thing about
your book that fascinates me is your
very first line
you said i never planned to tell the
story when i fled when i fled hell you
call it i made a pact with myself no one
would hear the details of what happened
to me in those previous nine months of
my life not my parents not my brother
yet you've written a book because you
want us now to know the story
why
i feel
you're only as sick as your secrets
i was tired of being afraid i was tired
of living in fear
i got to a stage where
i needed people to know my story because
i
i don't ever want
what happened to me to happen to anybody
else and when i first came forward i was
victim-shamed i was trolled i i was told
you were 22 you deserve to be raped no
gold digger i'm a gold digger for the
money i was in it for the money and you
know
and and and that really
triggered an anger in me that i didn't
even know existed like a fire
and what is the reality of that the
reality of that is the victim shaming
survivors don't come forward because
they're afraid to be judged they are
afraid that they won't be believed
because they they have made certain bad
decisions in their life
but i did not deserve to be raped
because of my bad decisions
i'm not a free-for-all where any person
has the right to just rape me whenever
they want
rape is rape gilan supporters
by that i mean her family has certainly
spoken very adamantly on her behalf say
because jeffrey isn't here survivors
like yourself just want to punish guelin
for jeffrey's misdeeds
but
that's nonsense and are really really
infuriates me
when people say that
i was forced into jeffrey's room
to be raped
by gilean
guillain
is as responsible if not more than
jeffrey
what would justice look like for you
as you sit here today
jeffrey's dead guilens here
i won't give him behind bars for the
rest of her life
purely because
she is that sick
the public are not safe
with her on the street
i want people to know what happened
and
me being and speaking and living my
truth
has set me free
it set me free
now of course we reached out to elaine
maxwell for comment but she did not
respond to us maxwell has pleaded not
guilty and firmly denies any wrongdoing
you know it was interesting talking to
sarah ransom because cbs has done
interviews with her over the years and
she says writing this book has been an
incredible healing journey for her and
the most powerful words that any
survivor can hear at this point are i
believe you
and she is getting a lot of that she
feels vindicated she feels validated and
she certainly feels gratified by the
support that she's getting and to see
gilan paint the picture of her role just
drives her nuts up
to be very candid about it
i still am absorbing the number of
people yes who have been affected yeah
allegedly by these two and perhaps we'll
never know the true number but there are
people who do know yeah right that's the
thing that is out there and it happened
for so long people know what went down
yeah she said something powerful you
were only as sick as your secret secrets
and for her to come out it serves as a
as a road map as a gps for young men and
women who are trying to navigate through
what can be a shark infested society
with predators preying on young people
and that's what she's hoping nate that
because it was so egregious what
happened to her that she didn't want to
talk about it for so long that other she
hopes other people will speak up not
necessarily about this case right but
other things that have happened to you
don't stay silent when you know that
you're being abused your words will help
those that are going through the same
thing